DANA PERINO, GREG GUTFELD AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
ELON MUSK CALLING TWITTER A
CRIME SCENE.
REPUBLICANS ARE VOWING TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF IT.
PART 5 OF THE TWITTER FILES
DROPPING HOURS AGO.
ONCE AGAIN, REVEALING THE
LENGTHS THE COMPANY WENT IN
ORDER TO CENSOR AND SUPPRESS
CONSERVATIVES.
THE GOP SAYS THEY'RE READY TO
ROLL OUT THE RED CARPET FOR MUSK
TO TESTIFY AT THEIR UPCOMING
HUNTER BIDEN HEARINGS AND KEVIN
McCARTHY IS VOWING TO HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE THOSE 51 SPIES THAT
DISMISSED THE LAPTOP STORY AS
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
>> THOSE 51 INTEL AGENTS THAT
SIGNED A LETTER THAT SAID THE
HUNTER BIDEN INFORMATION WAS ALL
WRONG, WAS RUSSIA COLLUSION,
MANY OF THEM HAVE A SECURITY
CLEARANCE.
WE'RE GOING TO BRING THEM BEFORE
A COMMITTEE.
I'M GOING TO HAVE THEM HAVE A
HEARING, BRING THEM AND SUBPOENA
THEM BEFORE COMMITTEE.
WHY DID THEY SIGN IT?
WHY DID THEY LIE TO THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
>> SO FAR IT'S CRITICS FROM THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, THE THREE BIG
NETWORKS, DEVOTED ZERO MINUTES
TO THE TWITTER FILES.
WHEN THE MEDIA DOES COVER IT,
THEY LAUGH IT OFF.
>> IF YOU WANT TO KNOW IF FUTURE
OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AS YOU
DISCUSSED LAST HOUR, TAKE A LOOK
AT THE COVER OF THE "NEW YORK
POST" THIS MORNING.
IF YOU'RE SITTING AT HOME
WORRIED ABOUT YOUR HOME HEATING
OIL BILL, YOUR GROCERY BILL, THE
STAFF US THE OF YOUR KIDS IN
SCHOOL, FORGET ABOUT THAT.
>> THEY CAN'T HELP THEMSELVES.
>> AT LEAST THERE'S ONE DEMOCRAT
THAT THINKS THIS IS A BIG DEAL.
>> IT IS WRONG TO CENSOR
L
JOURNALIST
JOURNALISTS.
THE "NEW YORK POST" HAS NOT
WRITTEN A KIND THING ABOUT ME.
THEY'RE A CONSERVATIVE POINT OF
VIEW PAPER.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU CAN
STOP PUBLISHING THEIR PIECES OR
ARTICLES OR CENSOR THEIR
JOURNALISTS FROM SHARING
STORIES.
>> JESSE, THESE TWITTER REVEALS
EVEN MORE SUPPRESSIVE DETAILS.
THE AMAZING PART OF THIS IS AS
WE WATCH THE REAL UNEARTHING OF
THIS SCHEME TO DEFRAUD THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC, THE DEMOCRATS
ARE SILENT.
NOT ONE OTHER THAN RO KHANNA
THAT YOU JUST HEARD IS WILLING
TO SAY, YOU KNOW, POLITICS
ASIDE, THE FIRST AMENDMENT, THE
RIGHT OF THE PRESS, FREE SPEECH
MATTERS IN AMERICA.
>> GOOD LUCK IGNORING THESE
HEARINGS.
IT WILL BE LOOK A GIRL IN A BAR,
TRYING TO IGNORE THAT.
THERE'S NO WAY THIS IS POSSIBLE.
THE MEDIA, ESPECIALLY THE D.C.
MEDIA LOVES CONFLICT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY LIVE AND
BREATHE FOR.
THESE ARE GOING TO BE HOT
HEARINGS.
THERE'S SENSATIONAL ALLEGATIONS
WHAT IS THE MEDIA GOING TO DO?
ARE THEY GOING TO COVER THE FARM
BILL?
THEY HAVE TO COVER IT WHETHER
THEY LIKE IT OR NOT.
THEY HAD THE JANUARY 6
COMMITTEE.
REPUBLICANS DON'T NEED THAT.
WE DON'T NEED EXECUTIVES ON TV
BLOWING UP THE SOAPS IN THE
AFTERNOON.
WE DON'T NEED HOLLYWOOD
PRODUCERS DOING IT.
WE DON'T NEED A 30-YEAR-OLD GIRL
NAMED CASSIDY BATTING HER
EYELASHES.
THIS IS AFTER THE TRUTH.
I'M NOT BEING DRAMATIC.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WITNESSES
BRINGING IN THE RICHEST GUY IN
THE WORLD TO TESTIFY UNDER OATH.
FORMER CIA DIRECTOR.
CURRENT FBI DIRECTOR.
BIDEN FAMILY BUSINESS PARTNERS.
WE MAY EVEN HAVE TO BRING IN
MIRANDA DIVINE FROM THE POST.
OR AN ESCORT.
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY GOOD.
NOW, WE KNOW CLEARLY TWITTER WAS
NOT A PRIVATE COMPANY.
TWITTER WAS AN FBI
SUBCONTRACTOR.
TWITTER WAS A DNC DONOR.
IF THE MEDIA WANTS TO SAY THIS
IS RIGHT WING CONSPIRACY, HAVE
AT IT.
TWITTER IS AT THE CENTER OF
EVERY CONTROVERSY WE HAD THE
LAST THREE YEARS.
THEY SAY THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
DOESN'T WANT TO KNOW ABOUT
COVID, DOESN'T WANT TO KNOW
ABOUT FBI SUBTERFUGE, DOESN'T
WANT TO KNOW ABOUT CENSORSHIP,
CHINESE SPIES.
OKAY.
YOU WANT TO SAY INFLATION IS
IMPORTANT NOW?
WE COVERED INFLATION FOR TWO
YEARS WHILE YOU COVERED JANUARY
6.
NOW YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
INFLATION?
YOU DON'T WANT TO -- YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO COVER INFLATION OR
THESE HEARINGS.
THAT'S THE POINT BECAUSE YOU
TONIGHT WANT TO.
>> ALL RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, DANA, ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE SEE NOW WITH THE
INTERNAL COMMUNICATIONS WITH
RESPECT TO DONALD TRUMP AND
WHETHER OR NOT HE WAS INCITING
ON JANUARY 6 AND THERE ARE
REPEATED E-MAILS, I DON'T SEE
THE INCITEMENT OF FEAR AND
THERE'S MANY OF THEM.
I DON'T SEE THE INCITEMENT ANGLE
HERE.
THESE ARE THE MONITORS AT
TWITTER.
BUT THEN YOU'VE GOT THE LAWYER
AND SHE SAYS THAT IT IS A
VIOLATION ON ITS FACE BUT WE
THINK THERE'S CODED MESSAGES
THERE.
>> RIGHT.
SHE WAS ONE OF THE FIRST PEOPLE
TO GET FIRED.
THE GENERAL COUNSEL.
AND THEN WE FOUND OUT THAT JAMES
BAKER WAS HER DEPUTY.
ELON MUSK FIRED HIM LAST WEEK AS
WELL.
THAT PART WAS INTERESTING.
COMPANIES HAVE RULES AND
POLICIES FOR A REASON.
GIVES YOU A ROAD MAP, THIS IS
WHAT WE CAN AND CAN'T DO.
THE MONITORS ARE SAYING THIS
DOESN'T VIOLATE OUR TERMS OF
SERVICE.
IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY VIOLATE OUR
TERMS OF SERVICE.
SO YOU HAD THE UNDERLINGS SAYING
WE WOULDN'T DO THAT.
THEY MAY NOT LIKE DONALD TRUMP
BUT THIS DOESN'T VIOLATE THE
TERMS OF SERVICE.
SHE WAS WILLING TO GO THERE.
THE THING I THINK IS VERY
INTERESTING IS JACK DORSEY, THE
CEO, NOWHERE TO BE FOUND.
HE TESTIFIED IN FRONT OF
CONGRESS SAYING THAT THIS
STUFFSN'T HAPPENING LIKE SHADOW
BANNING, FOR EXAMPLE.
SO WHEN ALL OF THOSE HEARINGS
HAPPENED, THEY WILL CALL ON HIM
AS WELL.
THE OTHER THING VERY INTERESTING
WITH THE MEDIA COVERAGE OF IT,
THE LEFT'S REACTION.
WE'VE HAD FIVE RELEASES OF THE
TWITTER FILES.
FOR A WHILE, WHEN THEY FIRST
COME OUT, THE LEFT IS VERY
QUIET.
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN, IT'S LIKE
A BAT SIGNAL GOES OUT AND THEY
GET THE SAME TALKING POINT AND
THEY SAY OH, THEY'RE JUST DOING
P.R. FOR THE RICHEST MAN IN THE
WORLD.
LAST WEEK IT WAS TWITTER JUST
DIDN'T WANT TO RELEASE NAKED
PHOTOGRAPHS OF HUNTER AND
EVERYBODY CAN UNDERSTAND THAT.
IT'S LIKE THEY GET ON THE SAME
PAGE AND THEY DRIVE.
THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO AVOID THE
HEARINGS.
THEY WILL BE THERE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN
OUT OF IT.
IT'S VERY INTERESTING.
WE'RE AT THE POINT WHERE YOU
HAVE A PRIVATE COMPANY THAT IS
IN CHARGE OF THE PUBLIC SQUARE.
THE HEARINGS ARE NOT JUST TO
HAVE A LOOK BACK.
WHAT DO WE DO GOING FORWARD.
THE LAST THING I WOULD SAY,
DON'T WORRY.
I WILL COVER THE FARM BILL IN
AMERICA'S NEWSROOM.
>> HAROLD, WOULD YOU HAVE BEEN
ONE OF THOSE DEMOCRATS OR
ANOTHER ONE DEMOCRAT ALONG WITH
RO KHANNA TO COMPLAIN ABOUT THIS
AND WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
CHANCES ARE OF ELON MUSK
ACTUALLY TESTIFYING?
>> I HAVE SAID THAT I THINK THIS
IS WRONG.
I THINK CENSORSHIP AT ANY LEVEL
>> RO KHANNA.
>> HE'S A UNITED STATES
CONGRESSMAN.
YOU ASKED ME THE QUESTION --
I'VE DONE IT.
I WOULDN'T BE A DIFFERENT PERSON
IF I WERE IN OFFICE.
THE KEY ISSUE IS OVERSIGHT.
THE ISSUE I'M MOST CONCERNED
ABOUT -- I COULD CARE LESS ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED IN TERMS OF 2020
AND WHETHER OR NOT THIS PRO HAVE
IT COMPANY DECIDED TO DO
SOMETHING THAT THEY SHOULDN'T
HAVE DONE.
WHEN THE GOVERNMENT GOT
INVOLVED, THE PRIVATE COMPANY
CAN DO WHATEVER THEY WANT IN THE
MARKED PLACE.
WE DON'T WANT THAT ANY LONGER WE
CAN SAY AS CONSUMERS.
SOME DEMOCRATS SAY THIS ISSUE OF
INVESTIGATIONS AND I THINK
THEY'RE RIGHT IN THIS REGARD,
THEY KNOW VOTERS AND SAID I WANT
YOU TO INVESTIGATE, INVESTIGATE.
VOTERS DID SAY THREATS TO
DEMOCRAT WERE A CONCERNS OF
THEIR.
IF THE FBI OR ANY ALPHABET SOUP
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WAS
TALKING ABOUT THIS COMPANY ABOUT
THE THINGS THAT ARE BEING
ALLEGED, AND THEY SHOULD BE
BROUGHT BEFORE THE COMMITTEE AS
WELL BECAUSE ITS THEIR WORDS
THAT GOT US HERE --
>> NO.
THEY PROVIDED THE E-MAILS.
THEY'RE GIVING US COVERAGE --
THEIR COMMENTARY.
JUDGE, I DON'T WANT TO ARGUE
WITH THAT.
WHOMEVER THEY CALLED BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE, THE ONLY CONCERN I
HAVE IS IF A GOVERNMENT AGENCY
WAS ASKING A PRIVATE COMPANY TO
CENSOR POLITICAL LANGUAGE.
IF THAT IS WHAT HAPPENED, THAT'S
A PROBLEM.
ALL THE OTHER STUFF, POLITICS,
RETRIBUTION, UNFORTUNATELY GO
HAND AND HAND IN TODAY'S WORLD.
CENSORSHIP SHOULD NOT.
THAT'S WHAT THE FOCUS SHOULD BE,
NOT ALL THE OTHER NONSENSE.
NOT HERE BUT IN SOME OTHER
CIRCLES AROUND THE MEDIA.
>> GREG, AFTER YOUR RESPONSE TO
WHAT HAROLD JUST SAID, ARE THOSE
51 INTEL GUYS GOING TO TESTIFY
AND SHOULD THEY LOSE THEIR
SECURITY CLEARANCES?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THAT IS -- I'LL TALK ABOUT THE
OTHER STUFF IN A SECOND.
A LOT OF THIS COMES DOWN TO
STRAIGHT BIAS.
BIAS ISN'T AGAINST THE LAW.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO DO A HEARING
ON BIAS, YOU'LL WASTE A LOT OF
TIME.
YOU WANT TO TAKE ABOUT THE INTEL
AGENTS, WHO CONTACTED THEM, WHY
THEY AGREED TO DO THAT WITHOUT
HAVING ANY KIND OF ED.
WHAT WAS IN IT FOR THEM.
I WANT TO KNOW ABOUT THAT.
I ALSO WANT TO KNOW ABOUT WHY
DID THEY TARGET A TOP DOCTOR.
THAT IS ANOTHER -- THAT'S A
THING OUTSIDE OF THE BIAS.
THE BIAS SPHERE.
I STOLE THAT.
I THINK THAT'S A SCOTT ADAMS
LINE.
ANYWAY, THAT'S -- IT'S NOT ABOUT
TRUMP.
THEY CENSORED SOMEBODY OVER A
LOCKDOWN THAT IS EXPERIENCE WAS
RESEARCHING LOCKDOWNS.
THAT'S A BIG DEAL.
>> HE'S THE ONE THAT SAID IF WE
KEEP THEM OUT OF SCHOOL THEY'LL
SUFFER.
>> THAT CENSORSHIP COST LIVES.
THAT'S A BIG DEAL.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS ABOUT FOUR
OR FIVE YEARS AGO, THE THREE
HORSEMEN OF THE MEDIA OF THE
LIBERAL APOCALYPSE.
THEY CONTROL ARTS, THE MEDIA,
ACADEMIA.
NATURALLY THEY WOULD CAPTURE THE
FOURTH.
SOCIAL MEDIA.
MUSK IS A CANARY IN A COAL MINE.
THIS TWITTER DUMP IS NOT AGAINST
THE LAW.
IT'S REFLECTING THE BIASES THAT
YOU FIND EVERYWHERE.
IF EVERYONE THAT WORKS AT
TWITTER IS A LIBERAL, THEN
THEY'LL ONLY SEE WHAT IS
THREATENING TO THEM AND NOT
THREATENING TO WHAT WE BELIEVE
IS THREATENING, RIGHT?
THIS IS A CONSEQUENCE OF
STAMPING OUT RIDE LOGICAL
DIVERSITY.
IT'S FUNNY.
WHEN YOU SAW THE UNTALENTED
ATTACKS ON MORNING JOE LAUGHING
ABOUT THAT, YOU CAN SEE THE
MIRROR AND WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
THAT WE FIND -- WE WERE LOOKING
AT THE JANUARY 6 COVERAGE.
HYSTERICA
HYSTERICAL.
IT'S ALMOST A PARALLEL HERE.
THEY LAUGH AT THE RIGHT WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT THE STATE OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION FOR KIDS.
WE DON'T WANT DRAG QUEEN STORY
HOUR, RIGHT?
WE DON'T WANT SEX ED FROM
ACTIVISTS.
WE DON'T WANT -- THEY WILL LAUGH
AT THAT AND GO -- THE THING IS
THEY'RE COMING THROUGH AN
IDEALOGICAL SPECTRUM THAT THAT
DOESN'T MATTER.
IF YOU COVER THOSE STORIES,
YOU'RE A SCAB.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SEEING RIGHT
NOW.
WHAT MUSK IS TRYING TO SAY IS
YOU NEED A BALANCE OF
DIVERSITY -- EVEN IF IT'S TWO
IDEAS, LEFT AND RIGHT.
WHAT YOU SAW IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE
OF WHEN THE LEFT TAKES OVER
SOMETHING, ALL BIAS GOES OUT THE
WINDOW.
THEY BELIEVE WE'RE NAZIS.
YOU CAN'T SAY -- THEY DON'T
THINK THEY'RE DOING ANYTHING
ILLEGAL.
THEY THINK WE'RE REALLY BAD
PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHY THEY NEED THIS.
IF YOU HAVE OTHER PEOPLE LIKE US